Yannick Guillot est un baliet solo
depuis 40 ans 40 ans de CDD comme tous
ses collègues musiciens de l'Orchestre
symphonique de la région Centre une
situation tenable lorsqu'il y avait de
l'activité mais c'est cette dernière
année le nombre de concerts lyrique et
symphonique a chuté de 32%. les salaires
également
si vous voulez le petit peu le revenu
moyen des musiciens de l'orchestre sur
2023 le calcul qu'on a fait on est en
deçà des 1000 euros
par mois donc on va vers une
paupérisation de l'orchestre
précarisation de l'orchestre il y a des
gens qui vont avoir des difficultés à
vivre ça c'est certain les musiciens
lancent une pétition ils souhaitent des
contrats à durer indéterminée ils
veulent aussi plus de répétitions et des
pupitres avec suffisamment de musiciens
pas question de saccager des oeuvres
majeures l'orchestre ne veut plus être
la variable d'ajustement du budget du
grand théâtre il y a des dépenses
nouvelles qui sont des dépenses de
fonctionnement qui sont des dépenses de
chauffage qui sont des dépenses de
matériaux qui rentrent en concurrence en
fait avec avec les salaires des artistes
budget total du Grand Théâtre 6 millions
d'euros par an seul la ville a augmenté
sa participation financière ces
dernières années de 570 000 euros pour
la municipalité la balle est dans le
camp des autres partenaires c'est le
moment vont arriver au mois de novembre
décembre le moment de
délibération sur les budgets des choix
donc voilà on examine tout les autres
partenaires ne n'ont pas augmenté d'un
seul euro depuis 20 ans la direction du
grand théâtre qui soutient son orchestre
symphonique doit à nouveau rencontrer
les partenaires financiers ces
prochaines semaines